so
his rights have to be
uh exercised early but one could you
turn it pregnant
all decisions must be hers because
ultimately
she is the most impacted there's just no
question and she ultimately has the
responsibility for that child
[Music]
so before we were married he promised me
we would have two kids and now he
doesn't want any more
my friends think i should trick him and
stop taking my birth control
men have never been in control of our
bodies we're the ones in control clap if
you think that she should trick him no
no
my people how would you check him i'm
next to everybody
so did you see that wow doesn't people
why was the whole room clapping
they're like yeah the two women in front
were like
i don't know
sounds like men's reproductive rights
are limited to the choice of whether or
not to have sex
and the choice
of whether or not to use protection
but what if he's tricked into fatherhood
or
what if he's not even the father
what does paternity fraud look like
it's ugly
it's extraordinarily you know we have to
distinguish paternity fraud in wrongful
paternity
what's the difference
wrongful paternity can be innocent
okay we went to a party i had sex with
six guys i think it was when i was
hanging out the window i got pregnant
but i wasn't sure
but you know if anybody knows that guy's
name would you please have them call me
and then she names one of the other guys
and he didn't have sex with her
it wasn't malicious wasn't intentional
she wasn't trying to harm anybody she
was just trying to figure out who it was
six guys in one night that's a [ __ ] yeah
what you doing in these streets that's a
lot i mean at least limited to two
like at least then it's like a 50 50
shot but six
six six
and you don't know which one shot up the
club
bro okay well
i'm not going to tell you how to live
your life but you know what i might
today
i wouldn't do that
no thank you yeah okay
wrongful fraternity
more often and less facetiously
okay i'm married i had an affair
[Music]
obviously here there's all sorts of
problems because there are more victims
than the person who's named his dear old
dad who may be the wrong one
there's everybody involved in the family
like a situation in texas
where the family had five little toe
head kids all guys all little blondos
and all of a sudden one day one little
blondo kids gets in trouble has to go to
the hospital i can't get a hold of mom
they get all the dad dad wrestles the
hospital
needs to give blood
whoops
can't do it wrong blood what wow
all the kids look
alike out it was the guy down the street
you've heard of this case no it's a real
case
so what happens to this family
can you
fathom what happens to this family
how do you think the kids feel when they
find out daryl dad isn't daryl dadden is
the guy down the street and i think dad
feels
that these five little boys and he still
loves dearly when he finds out they're
not his bio children but he still can't
tear away bruh they should go to jail
i think a [ __ ] who does that should
face jail time
i think she
she should have to pay some type of
compensation because that's
that's tough
jail for every year he spent raising
those kids she should put spend two in
jail make it equal
day
that was like honestly
i'm thinking like what's worse
if you raised a kid that's not yours for
three years or you went to jail for
three years and i literally think
raising a kid
is worse that's not yours because you
get attached to those kids you love
those kids like yeah you doesn't like
your own that's worse
i'd rather go to three jail for three
years than rate think kids like have my
whole world shattered
oh i don't i don't know and then men
have to go to jail for child support
they don't pay it so it's like
send these hoes to jail you all deserve
jail time
okay let's keep let's keep
because he going him he's devoted
himself to this how do you think he
feels
i mean it's
horrific
horrific
that's not wrongful that's deliberate
so that's paternity fraud that's
paternity fraud she knew who the father
was and lied about it
paul was right when he said trying to
understand the men's rights movement is
like trying to understand a snow drift
one snowflake at a time
there are unique father's rights issues
that vary between unmarried married and
divorced dads
but there are also men's rights issues
for non-biological fathers
[Music]
like this man who is facing jail time
for failure to pay child support for a
child that dna tests prove isn't his
cornell alexander still owes more than
30 thousand dollars to the state for a
child that's not his because the mom
wrote his name down because she needed
to name someone
no
heck no no
so you can just
write a random name down so if i
got pregnant didn't know who the father
was i could write ronald mcdonald
[Laughter]
i can write ronald mcdonald and then get
money from the ronald mcdonald
foundation
just because i put their that name elon
musk hey
according to this you can just put a
random name down imma put
bill gates
bill gates bro that's that's so [ __ ]
up that's the most [ __ ] up thing i've
ever heard what if i put down three
names
like elon bill
elon bill and jesus
booyah
you can be like what
in order to get wealthy your benefits
and i had to put him down as the father
that was the only way i can get the
system i'm almost homeless i'm almost in
jail
i'm out of work
my money is being threatened to be taken
he says the law needs to be changed so
when this happens as it often does
other men don't become dad by default
[Music]
because there's no such thing as mother
by default
like yes you're birthing it but nobody
can randomly put your name down so why
can you do that for
a random guy because they literally
don't care about men
they literally don't care
[Music]
a long time
you shouldn't have stuck your dick in it
that's what they always say it's like oh
you had sex with him too
shouldn't have bro
what have you been doing
also thank you for the five dollar super
chat i love how women act like this
never happened meanwhile 32 percent of
kids don't know who their real dad is
is it that high can you send me that
study if so send it on instagram
people wonder
about mris why are you guys so angry
and my answer to that is why aren't you
how can anybody look at this and not be
angered by it
and
the only answer to that i've ever been
able to come up with
is that people aren't angry because they
don't see men as human beings
[Music]